[Music]
[Laughter]
this show is brought to you by cash up
as you know cash up is the simplest way
to spend and save money and now it's the
simplest way to try to grow your money
introducing cash investing unlike
investing tools that only let you buy
entire shares of stock cash app lets you
instantly invest as little or as much as
you want
this way when your favorite company
stock is just a little too expensive you
can still own a piece with as little as
$1 and because cash app is directly
connected to your bank account there are
no four to five day waiting periods or
for inbound transfers so you can start
investing today brokerage services are
provided by cash app investing a
subsidiary of square and member s I see
download cash app from the App Store or
Google Play Store today
[Music]
congratulations can't believe we've done
140 for what we have and we've got some
I'm on tour Manama this is the I'm on
the follow the leader tour November 1st
I'll be a Foxwoods Connecticut November
2nd I've got a few remaining tickets for
in Pennsylvania in Bethlehem religious
and then some sold-out ones I think in
Rochester I think maybe there's a single
seats left Royal Oak Michigan Detroit
sold-out New Buffalo Michigan where is
it
Minneapolis is my taping I've been doing
my my show at the at The Improv I've
been performing there a bit run in my
hour mmm-hmm
if for Minneapolis for to shoot in
Minneapolis and my brother is directing
it because we like to try keeps it at my
fam but keeps it in the family Italians
we are Italian don't remember who says
that I think it's AG the rapper I can't
remember we keep sitting to the fam like
Italians anyway whatever
so Minneapolis my brother's directing it
so we're all set to do that and that's
that's so if you want go get tickets at
Chris Lea calm we got some coming up in
Hollywood Florida
El Paso Texas Houston a few shows Peoria
Illinois you know how it goes Chicago
come celebrate New Year's Eve with me
and that's and that's what's up so after
that [ __ ] man after I shoot this special
I'm gonna start doing new material I've
been doing this tour for almost two
years I think just trying to [ __ ] get
bags all over the [ __ ] place and do
different cities and [ __ ] you know I
have a shirt on that's like tan kinda I
like the shirt but it's definitely the
same color as my body so it makes me
look [ __ ] washed out all good yes
lost some hair [ __ ] woke up put my
hands through my [ __ ] scalp looked at
my hands Hey yes sir a bunch of pieces
of hair do it but I'm not even forty man
it's fine you don't you know what dude
I'm so goddamn I really live gentleman
Liam the youngest man you [ __ ] alive
what is this challenge changer there's a
random channel changer around and the
[ __ ] next to my computer for some
reason no TV even close so yeah dude you
know what's coming out you know what's
coming up this week you know what's
coming up this week man [ __ ] hell
Halloween or if you're a [ __ ] you can be
like All Hallows Eve you know what I
mean so Halloween is coming up and I
know we talked about this because we've
had Halloween shows before at the at
congratulations and [ __ ] because we've
been doing this podcast for about three
years but let's just send out some
reminder
man hey chicks and also douchebags
Halloween is one day not nine days so
you celebrate on the goddamn day and
that's it you don't celebrate seven
weeks early dude I mean I swear to god
people started celebrating in August man
I was out by the way my friends [ __ ]
friend had an outfit on I thought he was
drunk I thought he was dressed for
Halloween and he wasn't he was just
wearing it he was just fashionable
quote-unquote got mad got mad I was like
it's a little earlier from the dress on
Halloween found out that that's it's
just actual outfit got mad got mad so
good but I got mad where the mostly the
regular [ __ ] if you want to get crazy
and put one scarf on or wear sunglasses
as the [ __ ] Sun Goes Down fine but
don't get crazy at nighttime if you
weren't Sun sunglasses be blind be blind
I make fun of nobody who wears
sunglasses at night do you know why
because it's not fair
because they're blind and that's it
there are no exceptions if you're
wearing sunglasses at night you get
extra rights you're blind
okay yeah so you know it's like Canas
bring him back to baggy jeans getting
all pissed it's all good man baggy jeans
no I [ __ ] baggy jeans man remember
baggy jeans remember you used to wear
baggy jeans member james Van Der Beek
and varsity blues when he's leaning up
against the [ __ ] wall talking to the
chick and then it cuts to the wide shot
and you're like does he have another
does he have the rest of Dawson's Creek
and his legs dude james Van Der Beek no
have a little bit more [ __ ] tight
pants I remember I would wear tight
shirts and my uncle would be like that
sure doesn't fit and I was like yeah it
does anyway that's a [ __ ] regular
story but yeah so I was just you know
fashion is always gonna be like its it's
like cutting edge until like you're like
it's like annoying until it's cutting
edge and then you're like okay cool but
I swear to god I don't want to work I
don't want to have to work
baggy jeans again dude it'll end up
happening dude I'm gonna have the
baggiest [ __ ] jeans hmm I so I I'm
gonna have to bag his jeans I'm a little
[ __ ] Kevin Smith so but Halloween's
coming up Halloween dude chicks can't
wait for it to be Halloween I was
thinking about this man I was like
thinking about like you know because I
see on like Instagram going out to like
I see on Instagram like you know my
friend was showing me this [ __ ] chick
story and she was with like nine other
chicks and they were all dressed like
[ __ ] straight-up hookers dude here's
the thing man
I know this is like a hack premise but
like if you dress up as a [ __ ] [ __ ]
thing for Halloween you're a [ __ ] yuck
all good yeah uh can you if the only
thing over your [ __ ] nipples are like
leaves and you're like yeah but I'm
poison ivy great how much is it you know
dude oh you're a sexy mailman oh good
you're a sexy mail woman oh you're a
sexy dog catcher all good how much how
much is it for a second dude you know
just relax relax Halloween is all good
put on a [ __ ] UPS outfit button the
[ __ ] up
stop showing [ __ ] cleavage relax
yes [ __ ] you know if not fine but how
much so good but you start unbuttoning
that UPS outfit how much hundred four
thousand
yeah class
you know oh you're a [ __ ] you know
Pillsbury Doughboy with a skirt on all
good how many stacks and by the way it's
Monday it's all good but remember it
here remember who said it Crystal Leah
said it yeah [ __ ] you know or the guy
that's like [ __ ] how annoying is this
how annoying is this outfit
the guy who [ __ ] works out a lot and
just takes off his shirt and paints his
body green and he goes as the Hulk hey
man you're making everybody green at the
party you're rubbing up against hookers
making him green dude I have stacks for
the [ __ ] UPS girl and now she's green
guy I I should get half off if the
[ __ ] UPS sexy hooker is now [ __ ] a
little bit green cuz uh hey you paying
for this bro hey hey ho you paying for
this [ __ ]
you know how [ __ ] workout guy is it to
go as like a [ __ ] wrestler
you know I'm Hollywood Hulk Hogan I got
a blond mustache and I'm beefy dude I
just don't get like if you Rea if you're
a dad and you raised a girl and and like
she's like gets to the age where
whatever she's [ __ ] 18 19 I don't know
what it starts but like and then she's
just all of a sudden you she's like hey
Dad check out my halloween costume from
and she's at cutting college and she
sends you like [ __ ] look look I'm
[ __ ] you know I'm a Teletubby but that
but the tits parts are cut out instead
of a little television that they have
it's just her [ __ ] tits are out
why do your tits have to be out what
what chick wants what I want to know is
what chick wants more attention from
guys I want to know what girl wants more
attention from guys all you have to do
to get attention from guys is go into
Starbucks all you got to do is walk into
home deep shortened it Home Depot
all you gotta do is walk into a [ __ ]
IHOP and you're gonna be a [ __ ]
hooker UPS chick for Halloween for All
Hallows Eve
hey no all hookers Eve that's what it is
all hookers Eve and then the guy who's
the Hulk and his [ __ ] green makeup
his smearing all over his [ __ ]
shoulder and he's getting it on your
girl and you're like dude you're gonna
pay you're gonna buy her drinks nah bro
I'm just a Hulk man like I just don't
get Halloween man you're [ __ ] 23 Jude
Illinois I just don't I don't you know
the guy - hey man I'm risky business um
I got a leather jacket on in No Pants
okay lock him up
legal illegal
lock him up dude hi I'm dicks out guy
lock him up
dude how awful our Halloween costumes
for real like it what if like for real
those were the costumes that they used
in movies and like and [ __ ] like that
like if the x-men weren't done by like
like costume designers they were done by
like people who got drunk on Halloween
that movie would rip dude I'd watch that
like if they made a movie if they made
the movie like Dark Phoenix and they
were and they were like
like it was just like Nikki's outfit
she's like I'm dark Phoenix I'm dark
Phoenix and she's the girl I'm dark
Phoenix I'm Axemen and then it was her
saving the world and some guys [ __ ]
Colossus and he's just all painted
silver and he's got it in his eyes a
little bit and he keeps [ __ ] rubbing
his eyes cuz it's [ __ ] up his contact
and then at the end of the movie by the
end of the movie Dark Phoenix is a
little silver - cuz he keeps touching
her haha dude how many people are
dressing up is Billy Eilish tune in this
week do you I love the outfit that where
people think they're gonna be clever and
then they [ __ ] and then they get to
the party and there's like seven other
Billy eyelashes and they're like oh I
thought it was clever and there they in
the exact same outfit of the picture
that they schooled as someone else even
though Billy Alex wears like seventy
five different outfits they picked the
one that's popular on Google and they
see someone else and oh my gosh Ian they
have to pretend they're friends with her
or like how about this set how many sexy
Joker's are they're gonna be in like a
[ __ ] cropped you know purple suit oh
you know what the worst outfits are are
people who think they're funny with the
mean costumes when they're like when
they're like they have to hold something
dude if you're a if your costume
involves you holding something to stand
next to it go [ __ ] yourself huh
like the meme the why though meme or or
if you have to do a move so people get
the the costume you know like this this
meme somebody I saw somebody dressed up
as the the lady who goes I guess the the
the lady is like this like [ __ ] with
our hands on her knees and like you're
like who you dressed as and the guy's
like hold on a second and then he gets
on his [ __ ] he puts his hands on his
knees and you're like oh that you're
that [ __ ] idiot meme thing
who cares the best thing you can do the
best reaction you can get on Halloween
from your costume is this oh [ __ ] bro
that's the
first best reaction do you understand oh
[ __ ] look the guys dressed up as a
Freudian slip
he's on a slip and it says Freud on his
chest uh anyway let's get drunk the meme
based Halloween costumes you know the
guy dressed up as you know I had to do
it to him guy hey guy you just look like
a date rapist wow did I look grayish it
today it's all good man
due to my pasty white yup does it matter
nope does life still rip yeah yes dude
[ __ ] yeah man life
rips you know what I'm being for
Halloween pasty that's it I'll put on a
shirt maybe I'll put on some special
pants but pasty guy how about the
[ __ ] thing that goes like this on
Halloween ever if you're somewhere if
you're somewhere in Halloween during
Halloween the day and you can't hear
this
you're in a basement far underground or
you're in the middle of the [ __ ]
rainforest because every like 19th house
thinks it's like why is that a [ __ ]
thing that's nothing that's not even a
noise that is made ever anywhere but on
Halloween it's not a ghost you hear
ghosts if you [ __ ] Google ghosts and
you hear you you you put a [ __ ] a
thing on YouTube the boost the ghost
will go woo
or if you [ __ ] Google for real ghosts
the best you'll hear is this you know
what I mean I love that [ __ ] when you're
watching you there if you're there speak
speak to us if there say something we're
friendly we come in peace
cheer that who's that I really got real
cold all of a sudden you feel that cold
then the cuts are talking ahead and he's
just like I gotta tell you man I never
felt so cold in my life it was just like
a gust it was like all of a sudden I was
in the Arctic cuts back you there Roger
if you dare say something give us
something oh [ __ ] it's cold it got cold
did you feel that and then it'll be like
the EKG and the like play it back it'll
be like full cross oh [ __ ] did you hear
that play it back and then he was like
it cuts that are guys like he very clear
you said foie gras he very clearly said
foie gras cuz that's what he ate that
was his last meal before [ __ ] that
was his last meal before his on death
row for fraud make a noise it's just a
pipe you know it's a pipe [ __ ]
clanking it's house noises anyway what
the [ __ ] is like what [ __ ] decided
that was going to be
noise for Halloween I'm unplugging all
that [ __ ] when I get there and then
there's always that [ __ ] dude not
scary just a creaky door he is wd-40 I'm
walking around with wd-40 on Halloween
and [ __ ] my unplugging hand and when
I get to a place where I hear creaky
doors I just spray it in the people's
faces and then unplug with the other
hand I unplugged the [ __ ] what is
that thing even called how do you have
that thing Matt you go to the Halloween
stores bro there's so much weirdness
about Halloween
you know like Halloween stores you can
just go to a Halloween store and it like
opens in [ __ ] September and then just
closes November first and there are 45
of them in Burbank California you know
they just open in September and then and
then come November first literally shut
the [ __ ] down until next September like
hey how do you stay in business all good
how you stay in biz what I want to know
is how do you sell enough [ __ ] witch
masks and machines from September 20th
to October 30th to stay in business when
there's Amazon so [ __ ] weird that
Halloween stores are a thing I would
walk by one all the time when I was in
NYU and I would just be like houses
[ __ ] things stay in business and
they'd have the same costumes in the
windows in [ __ ] March I was like a
werewolf so weird mm-hmm here we go ads
my baby my babies Skillshare Skillshare
is an online learning community with
thousands of amazing classes
covering dozens of creative and
entrepreneurial skills you can take
classes in everything from photography
and creative writing to design
productivity and more other classes
include illustration graphic design
creative writing animation fine art
music a lot of cool things so whether
you're returning to a long time passion
project challenging yourself to get
outside your comfort zone or simply
exploring something new Skillshare has
classes for you they sent us a bunch of
courses to check out and I peaked at the
Entrepreneurship section you know
because I do business and I'm a business
man and I watched entrepreneurship
hustle from business plan to real
success and dude hello look at me look
at me now during the millions of
students already learning on Skillshare
today that's millions of people with a
special offer just for my listeners get
two months of Skillshare for free that's
right Skillshare is offering
congratulations listeners two months of
unlimited access to thousands of classes
for free to sign up go to skill shared
comm / Congrats again go to Skillshare
comm / congrats to start your two months
now that skill shared comm / Congrats
don't be an idiot guys you know you want
to learn blue apron yum one thing comes
to mind when I think about blue apron
YUM when I cook my meals at blue apron
yum dude come back to the magic of your
kitchen with new flavors and unexpected
culinary combination now I didn't know
I'd be a chef hello I'm a chef now
seasonally inspired produce step by step
cooking techniques and chef tested
recipes are just the beginning because
when you make dinner with blue apron
you're not just cooking you're creating
an artist and an eater
and a chef blue apron offers three
flexible plans the two-person plan
four-person family plan and the WW free
style plan you choose from a variety of
chef's design recipes and get perfectly
proportioned perfectly portioned
ingredients delivered right to your door
blue apron helps to make cooking at home
a sustainable part of my weekly routine
upcoming upcoming meals include
zatarra chicken and roasted squash if
you can't pronounce it you know it's
good
cheesy pesto baked cavatelli zesty beef
and yoky my mom would get it to start
making delicious brag worthy meals at
home without the hassle try blue apron
check out this week's menu and get $60
off when you visit blue apron concise
Congrats that's Blair from comm /
Congrats blue apron a better way to cook
so yeah like for real what am I talking
about about the about the Halloween
store oh man these fires are [ __ ]
crazy I got buddies [ __ ] being
evacuated yeah but what was I saying
about the Halloween stores the holidays
that are just the holidays that are just
for drinking are weird or that they turn
into it I mean Halloween is kind of one
that seems like that and then but like
Saint Patrick's Day was a real holiday
and then all of a sudden became the
thing where everybody just like drinking
and [ __ ] fighting and raping and [ __ ]
[ __ ] one fires phone went off that's
why he's one fire all good this texting
thing that I'm doing and by the way that
people are saying this is the weirdest
thing to me my number eight one eight
two three nine seventy eighty seven go
ahead and text me I
this truly baffles my this boggles my
mind this this whole thing this
community app thing I give my number out
and people can text me directly and I
text them back the there are very few a
very small percentage of people are like
oh yeah it's [ __ ] he's just trying to
get your infirmities getting making it's
just a money thing like all right look
here's what's up dude it's a it's a it's
a it's I'm I'm making zero money from
texting yo it's not a thing where I'm
making money from it
$0 there are people in my Instagram
comments like oh you [ __ ] you're
trying to do this it's all sellout no
money zero money zero money so I'm able
to now text people if they sign up for
this which is great
fine if you want to do it awesome if you
don't want to do it don't do it but some
people are like it's a scam what I want
to know is what's the scam what is the
scam what nobody's ever more specific
then it's a scam what's the scam what is
it you text me and I text you back and
now I own your liver what I want to know
these people are like what's this they
talk about it sometimes I'm like oh yeah
this whole scam what's the actual scam
what is it I don't even know what
example to make what could it be
now we text I texted people right now I
go on the thing right now look right
here
what some guy Colin wrote me what do you
do when you see a spaceman I'm writing
back I don't know look and I'm writing
what the [ __ ] are you talking about I
just texted that to Colin now what I
siphoned the money from his bank account
into mine what's the scam and then
people are like wow they just want your
direct information so you can dude
anybody in the world can tweet anybody
in the world and make their phone go
ding what's the difference about having
the [ __ ] being able to text someone
people love to make some [ __ ] out of
nothing dude also who gives a [ __ ] man
who gives a [ __ ] who gives a [ __ ] if you
have my personal information who are you
[ __ ]
you know the Riddler who gives a [ __ ]
who are you [ __ ] bin Laden who cares
so [ __ ] what now I know everybody now
I know who's texting me there I know
their name and I know what city they're
in so what what does that have to do
with scamming anyone I just these
[ __ ] dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] I drink
water or you [ __ ] I'll drink
water till I tear up dude there's no
scam man you text me i text you but boom
that's it baby
yes it's the same [ __ ] thing as
Instagram do you have me right now it's
the same [ __ ] I'm phone goes ding either
way it's the dumbest [ __ ] when people
are like are you with this [ __ ] what
is the [ __ ] law is to scam a I don't
get it
sometimes I fire out of [ __ ] I was in
San Diego I'm like San Diego I text
[ __ ] phone numbers I'm like I'm here
San Diego come on to the show I sent a
little video about me walking backstage
to all the people in San Diego bah boom
that's it no scam needed I'm already
[ __ ] I already you know like I just
it's just so [ __ ] weird the people
the the weirdest [ __ ] to me is when
people are like oh the government's
trying to get you and this has nothing
to do with this but like the
government's trying to get all your
information and use your facial for
technology and facial recognition and
CID and they want your info in that who
gives a [ __ ]
who cares I live a regular life I didn't
do anything shitty I'm just chilling I
never robbed the bank who gives a [ __ ]
I'm 39 my name is Chris I identify as a
female who gives
[ __ ] who [ __ ] cares now that you know
that what you're gonna do with that info
saw my legs off do you own my kidneys
are you siphoning my [ __ ] account are
you taking the dollar off every time I
drink a goddamn iced americano and
putting it in a [ __ ] offshore Swiss
account nah who [ __ ] cares dude my
name is Chris D'Elia I'm 39 I'm the
youngest man you've ever [ __ ] Matt
and I identify as a Korean filmmaker who
gives a [ __ ] now you know your
[ __ ] I drank so much water
right there
you should be proud of me this [ __ ] is
[ __ ] a silly goose time life will
continue to rip and life will never not
rip it will always be on the up whether
you [ __ ] have acne all over your face
you lose your [ __ ] feeling in your
feet or you [ __ ] develop cants life
still can rip because it's about the
attitude lose all your money life still
rips if you want it to rip look at the
sky look at the beauty there's a [ __ ]
rabbit running around maybe you're in
North Carolina and it's [ __ ] humid as
[ __ ] but you're living baby that sweat
means your body's overheating because
you're alive and life rips and yes
you know my underwears wet and I wish I
didn't wear jeans today but it's all
good wring it out quit what actually
makes a better tooth person I've been
thinking about this actually my whole
life ever since I remember my thoughts
in the beginning what makes a better
toothbrush industrial strength power I
mean I would be like six years old
maybe like is it industrial-strength
power I'd be seven or eight and I'd be
like is it claims of miraculous trendy
ingredients and then I and then I got a
little older I'm Moroni it's like eight
and a half I was like is it multiple
modes well look if you ask your dentist
they'll tell you it's less about the
brush and more about how you use it
that's why quip was created by dentists
and product designers to focus on what
actually matters for your oral health
healthier habits equips sensitive
vibrations with a built-in timer which
is very important the guide gentle
brushing for the dentist recommended two
minutes with 30 second pulses ensuring
in and even clean I do that I'll shut do
it for a little bit and then a little
and then I'll switch it over the side to
the side and my teeth they're whiter
than Christmas good habits matter to
live a healthier life so help form fresh
oral health habits with clip-clip starts
at just $25 and you'll get your first
refill free at get quip Calm / congrats
this is a simple way to support our show
and start brushing better but you have
to go to get qu IP dot-com / Congrats to
get your first refill free go right now
to get qu IP calm / Congrats intersect
announcing intersect festival by AWS
we're music art and technology converge
look I'm a big fan of music I'm a big
fan of art and I'm a big fan of
technology and when those confers
converge hello busting taking place
December 6th and 7th at the Las Vegas
festival grounds right on the Vegas
strip hello could you have a festival in
a better place no well you could in
Narnia but does Narnia exist no so let's
do it in Vegas
hello intersect you do that there it's
presented by Amazon Web Services born
out of the massive after party for their
reinvent conference now open to the
public for the first time ever so you're
welcome
it features the food fighters Anderson
PAC Kacey Musgraves Beck flag Lotus Leon
bridges her spoon Jamie xx Thundercat
churches
Randy Carlyle and more Ronnie Stone says
the festival has booked headliners to
rival that of Coachella and lined up
enough tech projects to build itself as
a mini South by Southwest selfish as
well South South by Southwest so here's
the deal dude you think you're cool
going to Coachella know the new thing is
intersect for a limited time
congratulations listeners can save $10
on a two-day general admission tickets
to intersect by going to intersect fest
comm and entering offer code congrats to
unlock the deal that's intersect fest
calm and promo code congrats to save
yourself some cash and be a part of this
incredible experience congratulations is
brought to you by Cash Shop the official
laughs app of the log cabin now did I
stutter and say someone you weren't
wrong yes is it okay yes other people
gonna get mad that fund the show maybe
is it okay ultimately it will be okay
yeah a Halloween doesn't scare me I used
to get so [ __ ] terrified as a little
boy like [ __ ] straight up straight up
terrified one time I couldn't spend the
night at my friend says I have I had a
friend that lived next door and I
couldn't do it Matt trevenna he lived
next door and I would try to go sleep
next door then I would just be like [ __ ]
it eventually I would just be like going
home and then I just run next door and
go home and knock on the door my mom
when interested like what's up a bit I
couldn't do her mommy and then she'd be
like alright get it we'll get you
sleeping back tomorrow mm-hmm and I
hated it you know I'm 39 now and yeah
I'm still the youngest guy alive but I
was even younger but could you imagine
even younger at 39 he was the youngest
man alive but could you imagine one day
long ago it was young there anyway um so
my mom was like you know it's okay if
you try to it's okay to be scared she's
like don't feel bad about being scared
you can be scared
and it's also okay to miss sleep just
try to stay over your friends house even
if you're up all night it's okay and
that was her at her [ __ ] wit's end
you know but she was really sweet for
saying that and even as a kid I knew
that she was like like on my side but
also like a little bit fed up and I was
like yeah but it makes sense I was like
I should try to do that he was like why
don't you just try to stay over so one
day did I tell you this story about
Freddy Krueger and Chris Siegel or
whatever I'll do it again
I don't think I have actually to be
honest I don't like I told this story
Chris Siegel who was one of the cool
kids because he lived on the other side
of town he was friends with Justin
McKinnon and just MacKinnon was really
cool too
they both like Freddy Krueger a lot
Justin McKinnon one time had a birthday
party and yet a sleepover and I wouldn't
even go to the sleepover part I told my
parents to pick me up at night because
they weren't they were gonna watch
psycho but before that they watched the
[ __ ] Bulls game and Michael Jordan
was playing and any time Michael Jordan
went for a shot
or I went for a slam dunk afterwards
Justin McKinnon would say Jordan what
the soil he would do it in a
high-pitched voice and I even as like a
youngster I'd be like why the [ __ ] is he
doing that in my old man brain he'd
[ __ ] slam dunk and Justin McKinnon
would go Jordan with the slam anyway I
left because they were gonna watch
psycho and my dad was like a kimbley
they're gonna watch psycho the kitchen
be watching psycho knows well I could
never watch that go if you think psycho
scary I left I went bye guys and
everyone went by and then Justin
McKinnon when Jordan with the slowed him
and then I [ __ ] went home one day
just a MacKinnon's friend Chris Segal
said hey won't you spend the night this
weekend and I said okay because I
thought about what my mom said I was
like you know what maybe I'll just spend
the night and I'll be awake all night
but who cares I knew I couldn't get home
because Chris Siegel lived in the
faraway part of New Jersey like it was
like you know 20 minutes away on the
other side of town so I knew saying yes
and confirming the sleepover would
absolutely make it so I would have to
stay over because I couldn't call my mom
at like [ __ ] 1 I am because she'd be
sleeping she's not gonna come pick me up
then
so I got to Chris Siegel's house and
apparently now that I'm older I realized
my mom told Chris he goes mom look I
know she called ahead I know Chris
Siegel like Fred Krueger Chris Lea is
really scared of Freddy Krueger 74 the
Kruger memorabilia
you know don't don't have it up or
something if you can help me out here so
I got into crystals room and there was
no Freddy Krueger stuff and I was like
Chris don't you like Freddy Krueger and
he was like yeah and there's like mom
took the poster down he had a Freddy
Krueger poster and and they took the
Freddy Krueger poster down and I looked
over at the world up poster and the only
thing that was shown on the rolled up
part like is that much you know just an
inch or Freddy Krueger's eyes swear to
God and I go like this all and she's so
oh I'm sorry and she turned it around
Christy goes mom that's how much of a
team player she was that's how much of a
[ __ ] I was so it's time for bed now and
we're going to sleep we're in his
bedroom and we're falling asleep and I'm
already thinking well I'm gonna be
really scared I can tell but we're
watching movies and I was like yo Chris
let's just stay up and watch movies all
night and he's like yeah alright cool
not knowing that I was saying that
because I was scared and I needed him to
stay awake in case demons came in to
snatch our bodies so or Freddy came out
from the unrolled from the unrolled the
poster and and [ __ ] came on and then
stabbed us in the heart as little kids
so anyway uh I'm like asking all sorts
of bullies like let's watch action
Jackson was on I remember with Carl
Weathers and he was like let's watch
this movie and I was like yeah I was
like cool he's really into it maybe
we'll stay up so watching the movie and
Chris Segal ends up falling asleep
and now I'm awake I keep trying to wake
him up and I do I use all those I used
like two or three times like I can't
keep doing this man he's gonna post he's
gonna tell everybody in New Jersey dude
thank god there's no internet back then
I would have been [ __ ] shamed so um
anyway
action Jackson ends
and I am I am like how do I fall asleep
I'll say I could just wait till the
daylight
I'll be good cuz I won't be scared in
the daylight anymore so I am sitting
there watching TV just [ __ ] he has a
TV in his room and I'm just sitting
there like imagine me just up
it's [ __ ] 2 a.m. as a ten-year-old
just looking around and chris Siegel's
just sleeping next to me you know and I
I'm like uh uh uh oh I by the way I'm
scared stiff because I don't want to go
anywhere else in the house I think
Freddie's gonna get me like this is
legitimate I'm not making this up
I thought Freddie was somewhere in the
house I was a [ __ ] I had a crazy
imagination and I was very scared so I'm
I'm like now now I think oh oh I didn't
think about this but I have to go to the
bathroom and I can't go anywhere because
I'm too scared
literally like my body won't it would be
very hard to move my body I'll say and
I'm watching the TV and the grumblings
in my tummy and I gotta go number two
it's not number one I mean numbered one
as well because you have to go number
one if you go number two but number two
was the focus so I'm like man I'm like
looking at if I had a watch back then
I'd be looking at it thinking like well
when's the Sun come up can I hold the
poop until the Sun comes up can i home
to poop in my anus until the scene can
the poop stay inside of my butthole
until the light comes with lights coming
over at 6:10 it's - it's great for hours
I Polly explode my pants so no no no I'm
gonna have already have to tick or I'm
probably have to make sure that Fred's
gonna have to kill me because it Boop's
gonna I'm gonna [ __ ] my pants you know I
mean like that's what I would have been
doing it so so um so I'm like [ __ ] what
do I do and I decide it must have must
be like 3:30 a.m. at this point I decide
I can't I can't really take it anymore I
have to [ __ ] but I'm like I'm gonna have
to make a run for the bath
room and do it because otherwise I'm
gonna [ __ ] my pants and not only am i
the [ __ ]
but Chris Siegel is gonna tell everybody
[ __ ] my pants in his bed so I'm like
alright I got to do this man you got a
man a men up go take a [ __ ] [ __ ]
your man dizzily because yeah you're a
man dude I know you're nine but your
[ __ ] man go take a [ __ ] in that
bathroom so I decide to do it and I'm
not bullshitting you this really
happened all right
I'm so [ __ ] tired but I have to [ __ ]
and I'm thinking about getting up to go
to do this the [ __ ] the TV is on the
news okay
the TV cuts to I don't know if it was a
news segment or what but it cuts to
there was on very low volume no volume
the cuts to a bedroom this is a new
segment it cuts to a bedroom and the
camera is on the pillow of the bed the
pillows of the bed and then it it shows
the foot of the bed outward and then
there's a door at the in from the
furthest part of the camera on the wall
and I'm watching this TV I'm like what
the [ __ ] is this because I can't hear it
cuz I don't know what they're talking
about the door opens and not lying to
you I wouldn't believe somebody if they
told me this but it happened to me so I
know it's true the door opens and it's
Freddy Krueger and he's got his [ __ ]
knife fingers and he's walking towards
the bed to the camera and I can't
believe my [ __ ] brain I can't believe
what I'm looking at I can't believe
what's happening the only thing I'm the
most scared of is Freddy Krueger and
right when I decide I'm gonna go have to
take a [ __ ] and make a run for it Freddy
Krueger's all of a sudden in the goddamn
room so now I think whoa I'm gonna [ __ ]
in this bedroom not in the bathroom
[ __ ] your world you made me [ __ ] in the
bedroom
[ __ ] it I'll be known as the [ __ ] the
pants guy in New Jersey I don't give a
[ __ ] I had these cutoff
remember to eye these red sweats that I
cut off into shorts and that was what I
was gonna [ __ ] in and I was well
prepared to do that I was like guess I'm
just staying here as a nine-year-old
alright Freddy you got me and then a cut
and it was gone I don't even know what
it was about maybe was about a Freddy
mover company Freddy Krueger movie
coming out googled it and tried to
[ __ ] YouTube it ever since that can't
find that clip and it wasn't me dreaming
dude I know some of you are like well
maybe you fell asleep when you had a vit
no dude it really happened so I'm like
what the [ __ ] am I gonna do I got to go
to the bathroom so bad and I'm like you
know what [ __ ] it I'll just wait until
the Sun comes up so I'm waiting and
waiting till the Sun comes up and you
know it's [ __ ] for it's probably two
hours away
I'm waiting I'm waiting I'm waiting I'm
waiting I'm waiting waiting next thing I
know I'm rubbing my face and waking up I
fell asleep I did it I [ __ ] did it
it's bright out I noticed it's bright
out I made it through the night but what
I also notice is that I did not [ __ ] my
pants I was currently [ __ ] my pants
look I know a lot of people have woken
up after they [ __ ] themselves
that's probably pretty common now I've
never done that in my life
ever in my life as a matter of fact I've
only [ __ ] in toilets my whole life I've
never missed I've never made a mistake
this time I woke up and I was currently
[ __ ] I woke up [ __ ] ha ha ha it
was that I'm gonna be gross but it was
half coming out and it was at a
standstill it was like it woke me up
because the [ __ ] came out and then was
just chilling
it was like let's just hang halfway out
until he wakes up woke up and it hurts
so bad I don't know I must have not
drink water in like [ __ ] 6 weeks and
I was like oh my god and the Sun was
coming up and I [ __ ] duck walked all
the way over and I by the way still
scared but already was [ __ ] so I I
duck walked all over to
bathroom and I let the rest of it come
out and it didn't even make a mess
because it was it didn't there was no
mass zero mass oh wow what a [ __ ] I
came with I'm telling the story so and
then when I was going to the bathroom I
let my fear you know how they like when
you're scared you could [ __ ] yourself I
let my fear just let the rest of it push
out because I was like oh my god I'm so
scared of my way I could use this to
shoot myself and so I [ __ ] in the toilet
and I was looking and there was a
[ __ ] I remember there was a what he
called it a shower curtain and I
remember I remember thinking like
legitimately like [ __ ] Freddie's
gonna pop out and [ __ ] kill me while
I'm [ __ ] I was convinced of it dude
I was the most scared little kid man and
guess what
I [ __ ] I went back into the room no mess
went back onto the floor next to [ __ ]
Chris Seagal fell asleep again cuz was
daytime it was easy and I [ __ ] did it
dude and that's your victorious
Halloween story I did it man
I met my mommy proud she said I could do
it and I did do it granted I [ __ ] myself
during it which is pretty much the worst
thing I don't know that counts is
actually doing it but I got through the
night and you can get through the night
too you can get through the night to
this that's why this podcast is for also
for like seven year olds it's
age-appropriate man oh my kid gets
scared at night so I could be there for
him
and just like pet his head I member used
to be so scared all the time
oh [ __ ] I used to have the most biggest
nightmares and my dad would come and
like just be like I'll just sit next to
your bed till you fall asleep so cute
and you would be like don't worry about
it it's fine sometimes he would be mad
you know because he had to work but
sometimes he would just chill it's
really cute
oh man I'll probably have the most
scared his kid [ __ ] karma number one
time my dad cut his hair didn't tell me
about it it cut his hair he had long
hair and came home once after work and
he had a [ __ ] short haircut and I
cried so hard
I was I saw him I looked at my way what
the [ __ ] you doing I just cut my hair
and he was like did it'll grow back I
got over it dude if you can get over
that you can get over anything six year
old seeing his dad cut his hair for the
first time my dad had like [ __ ]
ultimate warrior hair and then all of a
sudden had [ __ ] David Duchovny hair
come on dude if you can get over that
you get over anything people out there
say in the [ __ ] come on the drinking
on you [ __ ] do it I'm
respectful that's why so loud so loud
anyway
wow what else was I gonna talk about I
had something else can't remember all
good my memories gone need ginkgo biloba
I had a I had a man what else scared me
as a kid
keeping it Halloween Mike Myers I I
never saw Mike Myers movie when I was a
kid but holy [ __ ] [ __ ] that mask
scared the [ __ ] out of me Mike Myers
Freddy Krueger Jason obviously Chucky
not really used as like a doll Kevin
Nelson [ __ ] loved Jason and Freddy at
one time we got into a [ __ ] karate
fight and he was so his knees were so
knobby you [ __ ] me up let me ask a
question before we go actually this is
something I talk about on the group text
this drives me nuts dude a lot of times
that you know how I said I'm Bon Jovi
when I said and that's that there's no
changing it I'm Bon Jovi when I said
okay that's it that's it you might as
well [ __ ] cut the sleeves off to my
shirt because I'm Bon Jovi when I said
my [ __ ] eye man spread and I don't
give a [ __ ] if you're uncomfortable it
chill
um tease my hair out cuz I'm Bon Jovi my
knees can't get further apart
I'm like a [ __ ] [ __ ] okay a lot of
times I'll hang my knee over a chair
I'll hang my knee over a [ __ ] what do
you call it a table I'm chillin I'm at
cafes a lot and I'm doing this this week
I was at one it'll remain nameless and
the girl comes up to me that works there
and she was like excuse me can you take
your foot off now look I get it if my
feet are on furniture not okay feet are
dirty the feet shoes they've got piss
all over them because you walk around in
toilets and bathrooms and [ __ ] you piss
and the back [ __ ] piss gets on the
[ __ ] [ __ ] and the bottom of the thing
you step and [ __ ] piss [ __ ] all over the
[ __ ] right so I get that I never put my
feet on furniture like that okay Mike
half yes my calf all right can you take
your foot off she says and I roll my
eyes at her and I say yeah sure okay and
I go like this okay and I here's how you
know I'm pissed I go right to the group
text and I say god damn [ __ ] why
do I always dude I get so much people I
get so much [ __ ] from establishments for
doing the Bon Jovi spread and I'm just
chilling man that's that is a [ __ ]
rule that isn't should not be a rule if
you sit with your feet up it's okay
you're not gonna you can't tell me what
to do with my body dude I'm a FEMINIST
you're not gonna tell me where to put my
limbs it's not a health hazard to put my
[ __ ] calf on a table I talked about
with the group text and like why to get
so mad about this oh it's really it's
you know it says one of the other more
my other buddies is like well I'm like
you can't thumb will do my body is like
they're not they're telling you they're
telling you how to be polite in their
establishment let me tell you something
here's my
Buttle no I'm chillin dude can I not do
this cannot do this can I not do this
can I not do this can I not put my leg
up can I put my leg up in the air like
this would you tell me to put my foot
down if I had to up an air like this
would you tell me to put it down no you
wouldn't okay well let me put it this
way what about if it's like that on the
other caps on the table but the foots
off the table you would wouldn't you you
would you would have a problem if my
[ __ ] foot was on it wouldn't you
no let me ask you a question what's the
difference between that and that what's
the difference dude what's the
difference between us it's down to the
penis and well nothing I don't give a
[ __ ] I really mean that what's the
difference between this and this what's
the difference dude and you're gonna
tell me not to do the thing like this I
should have one like this sure yeah I
won't do it sure sure sure
there you go how's that Australian chick
because she was Australian skis mate can
you talk your things over the language
thing sure yeah I can do me a favor real
quick though call yourself a kangaroo
God that made me mad yeah I'll move my
limbs for you because it's your body not
mine I'm a FEMINIST baby you know tell
me what to do with my body wrong one
always hit the wrong one easy yes I'm a
FEMINIST baby I'm a [ __ ] feminist
baby
dude don't tell me where to put my
calves dude I'm serious man
I'm gonna run for [ __ ] local mayor
and I'm gonna say this calf situation is
out of control
hi I'm Chris Lea's calf situations out
of control a lot of times when you're
sitting with your feet up at the cafe if
your feet aren't even on a table or the
back of someone's chair
people will say come up to you and say
can you please put your foot down well
I'm here to make that stop
I'm Krista Leah and I'm running for
[ __ ] mayor of Lompoc and I understand
that a lot of you guys you got out
trying to do the Bon Jovi sit-ins and
they're not letting you do the bun jovi
sit-ins well that's not okay on my dime
that ends today vote for me I had paid
for by Chris Aliyah cuz it's Chris
D'Elia before I hit the jeremy renner
one one more time I'm gonna [ __ ] it
just it's just don't tell me where to
put my [ __ ] limbs Oh
ma'am Oh Oh ma'am is my dick inside you
know then stop complaining
Oh ma'am this is cafe right uh ma'am I'm
inside you what if I did that what if
she said can you move can you be can you
not put your feet on the table and I
said oh do it ma'am is my dick inside
you let's key is my I'm asking you if my
penis is inside is inside of you in any
of the in any of the holes that you have
I know oh cool
then don't tell me what to do with my
body
a single greatest music drop of all time
Thank You Jeremy Renner dude I [ __ ]
remember when I was a kid I take all the
[ __ ] can
so do things and I cut them all because
I thought that killed dolphins and
turtles that's it's a sham David
everyone [ __ ] says this [ __ ] paper
straw thing is such a [ __ ] dude zero
turtles you're saving ice I'll tell you
what man I'll tell you what I'm gonna
start wearing paper bathing suits that's
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna wear paper
[ __ ] bathing suits and when people
say why you were in a paper bathing suit
and I say well because it's okay to put
paper in water did you know that and
they say no it doesn't I said what do
you mean no it doesn't I said well the
paper gets they say well the paper gets
all [ __ ] you know watery and then it
ends up falling off and your dick isn't
up getting exposed and then I say well
then why are we putting paper straws in
cops smoking the fattest stogie dude and
you don't even know I had one until then
forget the [ __ ] cigarette cigar
something something some old
[Music]
dude I'm wearing paper bathing suits
period and then when people say why
weren't a paper brands do I say for the
turtles for the turtles sure your dick
is coming out you're wearing loose leaf
paper around your balls yeah it's for
the turtles this whole world is so
backwards dude from [ __ ] people
saying the phone number thing is a scam
to [ __ ] paper straws hey paper in
liquid I farted when I went like that
I'll be honest I went and you didn't
hear it cuz I would but I would dude
you can't put paper in liquid that's
something we know we don't even have to
learn it it's intrinsic in our knowledge
so ridiculous [ __ ] [ __ ] what's
that song decklist
what's that song dude I'm gonna text
somebody back right now somebody writes
when's my sweatshirt gonna ship papa
don't call me papa it did I wrote him
somebody wrote go [ __ ] yourself you're
not funny okay not writing him back look
at this look at this people get so mad
since you hit me with a mass text no
thanks dude you know these [ __ ]
people man
I literally have 64,000 people here how
am I suppose I'm a Janine mad that I
didn't respond to you
that's so funny man people are so
ridiculous so appalled is what it is I
can't play it coz then we'll get [ __ ]
flagged but he goes [ __ ] ridiculous
all right dude I'm out download the cash
up for free on the App Store or Google
Play market text me eight one eight two
three nine seventy eighty seven oh and
we got the merch man we're selling out
the life rip stuff we got a reorder
coming in I know the bead the medium
sold out I think but go to crystally
accom or store Chris D'Elia com
subscribe to the YouTube channel hey and
I'm gonna ask you guys tell a friend
about this podcast all right it really
will help it really will help the
podcast grow and I really want the
podcast to grow because you you know
honestly if this podcast gets bigger and
bigger then I have thought about doing
like two a week sometimes but I'm not
going to do it at
point so if you guys push this podcast
and share it and tell your friends about
it and get people on board to be in this
log cabin one day and grow babies and be
a part of this cult and nots you know
what I mean like it will help subscribe
to the YouTube channel to want to have
400,000 subscribers we're at 398 K so
help me out dude if you're a baby help
me out subscribe rate and review the
show that helps thank you very much for
listening we'll see you in Foxwoods will
see in Bethlehem Pennsylvania we see in
Rochester we're seeing Royal Oak Detroit
in the Buffalo Minneapolis tape of my
special Tampa Florida Melbourne Florida
and Hollywood Florida
El Paso Houston Peoria and Chicago
Illinois Minneapolis from shoot my
special can't wait I see a florida and
texas and all the other [ __ ] alright
guys you guys are great thank you very
much
[Music]